There've been a lot of craze leaders throughout history,
many of which we've looked at on there's a very channel,
but few have been as depraved as the man who absolutely brutalized Uganda
throughout the 1970s with his pension for torture severed heads,
and it's by his own admission cannibalism.
He thoroughly deserved the description given to him by the man he replaced as
Ugandan presidents,
Milson a boat,
a the greatest brew to that an African mother has brought to life.
In this week's bond graphics.
We ends up the very bizarre wells of any amen.
Idi Amin data was born between 1925 and 1928 in Koboko Uganda.
His was the [inaudible] tribe,
if which his mother was the witch doctor.
He had very little formal education but was versed in the teachings of the Koran
from a very early age.
In fact,
he developed a reputation as the boy who could recite the Koran in his early
teens.
He won an award for this ability young at spent his days in the fields tending
goats in his mid teens.
He got his first job as a hat and coat person at the imperial hotel in the Gaza.
It was that that he came to the notice of a British army,
offset it.
He had grown into a tall,
strapping young man.
He spoke the Kiswahili language and he had little education,
meaning he would readily follow orders.
These were all seen as desirable traits and the officer pulled some strings to
allow him to enter the British colonial army.
In 1946 it he began his military career as the laundry worker in the Margaret
Margaret barracks in junior.
After a year of this,
he advanced to the 21st King's African rifle core at g league.
Shortly thereafter,
his unit was relocated to Somalia and he proved to be a keen,
eager soldier,
his courage,
boldness,
and cruelty.
What traits that Martin as a standout private after hunting down shift to animal
Raiders in Somalia,
he was sent to Fort Hall where he began training for the Scottish military
bands.
By the age of 20 [inaudible] had grown into a young Bam off at six foot four.
He weighed in at 240 pounds and he was as strong as an ox.
He excelled at boxing becoming the Ugandan light heavyweight boxing champion as
well.
There's an accomplished swimmer
over the next two years.
Idi Amin data established himself as an ideal soldier.
One report described him as an incredible person who has certainly not mad,
very shrewd,
very cunning,
and a born leader and other report commented on his physical and mental ability
at stating a splendid and good rugby player,
bit of virtually bone from the neck up and needs things explained in words of
one letter in 1952 I'm in.
His Brigade was dispatched to Kenya to fight against the Mau Mau rebellion.
Yeah.
He undertook foot patrols in the jungle to root out the rebels.
His initiative was rewarded by promotion for us to corporal and then to
sergeants.
By the end of 18 three here,
Dan's the highest strength that a black officer could attain in the British
colonial army,
and that was the [inaudible].
This was the equivalent of a warrant officer housing down the Mau Mau.
It wasn't the only thing that I'm in.
Did wanting Kenya during those two years.
He also fathered two children,
a boy and a girl.
They were to be the first of 35 children born by five wives.
In 1954 I'm in his brigade returns to their base that ginger and Uganda,
when Queen Elizabeth Taught,
he was in the Scottish army.
Band's winning the distinction of being named the best in parade.
In 1957 he led a movement among the native soldiers to get increased salaries.
The initiative it failed,
and the army brass expressed displeasure at this upstart move from Nestar.
Soldier disappointment came when he twice failed the military intelligence test.
As a result,
he was transferred from the fields,
do the king's African rifle core bands.
Then in 1959 he passed the army field exercise examined was permitted once more
to serve in the field of combat.
He was posted to the border between Kenya and Uganda and here there was a bit of
rivalry between the Ugandan Carramar Gong ans the Kenyan to kind of nomads.
He arrives in the wake of a crushing British defeat at the hands of the Takata
performed so well.
There's a British officer described I'm in as having restored the prestige of
the forces of law and order in the region of Karamoja.
In fact,
I'm in now promoted to 10 and twist responsible for negotiating a peace
agreements with the Tacoma leader,
Edward Matea.
I'm in his means of achieving his ends on all the docs.
Do you see the least?
He threatened to cut off the penis of every TACAN,
a man who was found to be rustling cattle,
and this wasn't just bluffing.
He followed through on this threat and much more.
In fact,
he bloody manner in which he crushed the rebellion,
brought a level of ferociousness to the area that was simply unprecedented.
In 1962 you're going to one independence from Great Britain.
Suddenly the nation had its own army,
whereas previously the native brigades had been treated as second class soldiers
by the British and we're doing the bidding of that colonial overlords now.
They were free of those shackles.
A large number of British officers remained in Uganda to oversee the emergence
of the Ugandan army as early as 1964 and began making moves to gain military
strength within the Ugandan army.
His actions in putting down the Takotna rebellion brought him to the attention
of Uganda's first Prime Minister Milson to Bowtie.
He promoted the hawking young fighter to the position of deputy commander of the
army.
He was also putting commands of the first battalion of the Ugandan army in 1965
I'm in that his battalion into the Congo to support nationalists and resist the
foreign sport in government that the mission was been successful with the again
and forces being repelled by the Congolese mercenaries.
Later that year by men became entangled in a scandal involving the smuggling of
golden livery,
President Frederick and the tastes and the second did his investigation about it
responded by making them in general and chief of staff and tossed him with the
strong handling of the situation.
Even funny of ministers arrested and some named himself as presidents I'm in,
was dispatched with an army false to the place of President Matesa.
I'm in personnel personally.
Five to 12 millimeter gun that was mounted on his jeep to blow holes in the
president's palace walls.
We taste however,
he had gone into hiding and managed a fee to England in 1969 [inaudible] was
pleased with the strong man tactics of his right hand man.
Ed.
I'm in.
In 1967 he gave him the come on David the army.
That same year it he enrolled at university and took English classes.
He would eventually receive a doctoral degree from the university.
In 1969 idiom means leadership of the Ugandan army that was challenged.
The aghans in people's Congress were attempting to bring about reforms.
They had major concerns with the tactics that the commander in chief was using
to exert his control.
He had established a pattern of brutalizing his enemies,
fermenting massacres against communities that appeared rebellious and executing
opposition leaders recognizing the shifting winds and began to take courses in
social.
Yeah,
I'm in this brutality.
However,
it could not be quelled when he was accused by brigadier general acquire of
complicity in an assassination attempt on president of biotech.
I'm in arranged for acquire to be assassinated.
Meanwhile,
tensions that develops between a boat and then it he had focused on recruiting
soldiers from his own tribe in order to build up his personal following.
Then it was proven that he had indeed been behind the attempt on a boat,
his life.
At the same time,
it was revealed that he had misappropriated 40 million shillings from the
military operations fund in 1970 a boat a at.
I'm in fired from his position as commander in chief of the army and instructed
as attorneys do prepare a prosecution against him to avoid arrest.
I'm in flat to Kampala from that and he waited for his opportunity to strike
back at a bowtie.
That opportunity game on January the 25th 1971 on that date,
president about her was attending a Commonwealth summit meeting in Singapore
with the aid of Rwandan rebels.
He staged a bloody Cooper claiming himself.
Both prime minister and the president are those.
Jay heard about this on the flight home from Singapore and diverted his flight
to Tanzania over the last couple of years of Jose's relationship with the
western powers had been increasingly turbulence as a result of the change of
government was actually welcomed by Western governments.
Indeed,
Ibotta was also so unpopular as home that the majority of Ugandans celebrated is
overthrowing the western powers that high hopes for this new your gums and
regime.
They felt that our men would be able to check Russian influence in the region,
what they knew of any amen they liked.
He was a sportsman and national champion box and a man who had failed the army
intelligence exam.
You have gone on to receive a university doctorate.
What they didn't realize was that I'm in was a dictator of unprecedented
ruthlessness.
I'm in.
This rule began with the number of concessions political prisoners were
released.
The secret police was disbanded any promised the people that free and open
elections would be held,
but it didn't take long for his true nature to show itself.
He extended his period of caretaker governance from 18 months to five years.
His reasoning was that he needed a time in order to reform the government in a
way that would truly benefit the nation.
I'm in,
began to award himself and increasingly bizarre succession of titles,
including Lord of all beasts of the earth and fishes of the sea.
In August,
1972 you set his sights on reforming the economy.
In doing so,
he identified a scapegoat for the country's financial worries and that was the
Asians.
His solution was drastic.
All Asians,
even those holding British passports were expelled from Uganda.
He laid to reveal that he had been given the message.
Do you expel the Asians in the vision from God himself?
The 70,000 affected people were given 90 days to leave the country or face
arrest,
imprisonment or worse.
What's more is they could only take what possessions and money they could carry
with them.
All property that's behind would be shad among I'm in his cronies having rid of
the country of the Asian problem.
I'm in,
sent out raising the country of anyone who was associated with the former
regime.
Assassinations became routine and extended to those even just associated with
the old British regime.
Then British businesses and property began to be confiscated by the government.
British Jewish residents were expelled.
Great Britain and Israel responded by cutting off all diplomatic relations with
Uganda.
Those countries also stopped supplying garments to the retreat
I'm in now.
I want to find a new supply of arms.
He found it in Libya in order to achieve that agreements,
I'm in promise that country's own dictator Muammar Gaddafi that he would convert
the nation to Islam.
The Ugandan dictator also turn to Russia for military support is giving them the
assurance that he would serve as a stalwart of resistance against the western
powers and he also gave his support to the Palestinian struggle against Israel
back home.
I'm in made sweeping changes within the structure of the army.
36 leading officers were told to report to McIntee prison for special training
and subversion techniques,
but when they got there,
they found themselves being thrown into prison cells or 36 within bayoneted
death.
Former army chief of Staff Brigadier Silliman has seen,
was arrested and taken to another place of confinement that the men who were
formerly under his command beat him to death with their rifle butts.
That wasn't all that happened to him.
His head was cut off and sent to amen that his new house in Kampala and he had
the grizzly trophy placed in the freezer compartment of his refrigerator.
Top army officers are the two main barracks in the country where it's told that
they were to line up on the parade grounds in order to salute an incoming
motorcade of tanks.
On both occasions,
as the tanks came close,
they ran off course and knocks down the startle officers.
Those that weren't crushed to death were shot by waiting rifleman and he has
another barracks.
The office call were assembled in a room and told them that president was on
route to deliver a lecture bus.
As I'm in his entourage and did the barracks grenades were thrown into the room
and all of the officers were killed.
Within a few months,
nearly every trained army officer in Uganda had been eliminated.
They were replaced by members of a men's Kakoa tribe.
Men who had been tending goats in the fields became high ranking generals over
night.
I mean,
it was largely able to keep the slaughter that was occurring in the army from
the people as well as the international community bus.
When the murderous rampage was extended to the people in general,
the mosque of civility,
it was ripped off in the name of protecting the order of his regime.
More than half a million Ugandans were killed.
No one was immune with a murder.
Tall taking and chief justices,
doctors,
lawyers,
diplomats,
teachers and journalists,
foreigners.
We're also mattered now,
just before we get into even more madness and I promise it gets worse,
like feeding heads do crocodiles worse as well.
You probably don't have to worry about that if you do have to deal with the
risks,
do your online identity.
Whoa,
Simon,
I hear you cry.
We suddenly in an ads,
what happens?
Yup.
Well,
decompression,
sickness aside.
Ads are important because they do help us pay for these super long videos,
but stick with me.
Like I said,
there's crocodiles being fed,
human heads coming up and he wouldn't want to stick around for that.
Am I right?
Also Dash Lane,
it's very cool and it's basically it's free so there's also that dash lane is a
one stop digital identity protection tool that includes a VPN for all of your
devices so you can use public internet safely and anonymously.
They also do something called dark web monitoring,
which basically means that they monitor the nasty underbelly of the Internet for
people selling your data and they will alert you if that is happening further.
If a service you've signed up for like Equifax or Sony maybe suffers a breach
dash lane,
we'll tell you about it right away and they'll also let you do other services
that share that username and password so you can change those before hackers get
access to your data on other sites.
Plus Dash Eileen does what he's always done.
It stores your passwords,
it keeps your personal data secure and it fills all of those annoying boxes for
payment info in passwords for you.
A lot of the dash lane is totally free,
but there are some premium upgrades you can buy if you want more from the
service to see if those are right for you.
You can also get a free 30 day trial of them and after that you can get a 10%
discount using our code biographics@dashlane.com forward slash buyer graphics
and let's get in and do those crocodiles and being fed human heads showering.
Unlike many other brutal dictators I'm in,
took a personal hand in the slaughter.
In fact,
he rather seem to revel in it.
He would personally torture people and then feed their heads to crocodiles.
You also proudly spoke about eating the flesh of his enemies and as we've
already seen,
he had a thing for preserving their heads in his fridge.
On one infamous occasion in 90 62 I'm in was hosting a state dinner at his
palace and halfway through the meal he left the table.
You need to return with the frozen head of Brigadier Silliman Hussein and his
hands.
There's a goest guests to know where to look.
As he proceeded to director barrage of abuse at the hands and then through
cutlery at it,
the new and expanded army.
It needed funds and I'm in,
got them by diverting,
much needed tax income away from things like education,
infrastructure and health and put it into the armed forces.
Army courts were given greater prominence than civil courts parliament.
It was dissolved and all ministers are threatened with arrest the ball on an
ratcheted up.
The terror,
the more paranoid he appeared to become,
he surrounded himself with a security detail which numbered as many as 18,000
these men doubled as a ruthless death squad.
Murdering,
raping,
and pillaging at will on average between 40 and 50 bodies were thrown into Lake
Victoria every single day.
In 1972 ousted president of boat,
a based in Tanzania began making plans to retake.
Power gathering is false.
He made some incursions across the border.
I'm in retaliated by bombing Tanzania and towns just across the border.
This effectively put an end to a boat as ambitions for power.
While the is chaos was taking place within his borders.
I'm in was not shy about acting on the international stage.
He offered to broker peace in Northern Ireland's and courage the Scottish to
break away from the Commonwealth and told African countries that they should
unite to oppose South Africa.
He became the chair of the Organization of African Unity.
Oau advocating that the consonants completely separate relations with the West
even went as far as to declare that he not Queen Elizabeth was the head of the
Commonwealth and accordance with this belief we then awarded himself the
Victoria Cross
in establishing links with Russia in Libya.
I'm in offered his support to the Palestinian Liberation Organization or PLO
when numbers of the PLO hijacked a plane en route from Tel Aviv to Paris in June
of 1976 and then invited them to lands the plane at and t they app or with 256
hostages to bargain with veep to PLO.
Hijackers demanded the release of 53 PLO prisoners held by the Israelis only on
one of the hostages and elderly person by the name of Dora block chokes on some
food and was transported to compile a hospital.
I'm in,
threw himself into the drama.
He quickly,
he got himself to the APP autumn's in front of the hostages.
Images of him berating the passengers were shown all around the world.
156 passengers.
All of those who did not hold Israeli passports were soon released.
Leaving 100 hostages ironically had the antimony airports had actually been
designed by Israeli engineers back in Tel Aviv.
They were able to pull out the plans for the airports and identify exactly where
the hostages were being held.
The Israelis then devised a plan to rescue the hostages and the early morning
hours of July the third a team of Israeli paratroopers has rated the apples in
the ensuing firefight.
Three of the hostages were killed with another 10 being injured.
Seven of the hijackers along with some 45 Ugandan soldiers who fought in support
of the hijackers were also killed as it was.
One of the rescue is overall though the rescue,
it was a stunning success.
I'm in,
was furious with a ton of events with no one else to vent anger on.
He ordered a couple of his thugs to the compiler hospital.
They bust into the room that door a block was in and as they dragged the older
woman away,
she was never seen again if the world didn't realize that the Ugandan dictator
was stark raving mad.
His stated intention to build a memorial to adult Hitler left them with no
doubt.
Following the raid on Entebbe almonds grip on Poway always beginning to weaken.
By now the economy was a disaster and attempted k was staged in 1977 that one
successful,
it ratcheted up.
I'm in his power levels to an all time high.
All of those suspected in being involved in the plots where executed with entire
on the units just being wiped out.
Then in an attempt to galvanize the people,
he spread the life that the tens and neons were about to invade.
He mounted a series of preemptive strikes against the supposed invasion.
However,
he refused to pride as support for the ground attacks.
This led to the needless deaths of thousands of his troops.
The Tanzanians pushed the invaders back ans then surged into northern Uganda.
I'm in an intended for the wall with Tanzania to be a distraction from the
problems at home,
but the plan it had backfired as the troops surged into the country,
locals joined them and a spontaneous effort to reclaim that country with the
ever growing tends in the end and local forces.
Closing an Kampala,
I'm in,
made an urgent broadcast urging the army to make a stand standard geneal,
but by now the only two has abandoned him and the call.
It was simply ignored.
Seeing the writing on the wall,
along with his five wives and 35 children fled to Libya where they were given
sanctuary by Muammar Gaddafi.
I'm in left his country with an inflation rate in excess of 200% a national debt
of $340 million and the corpses of between 300 and 500,000 of his own people as
the people struggled to recover under the reinstated presidency of Milton.
A boat day I'm in and his family lived in relative luxury under Gaddafi is large
ass.
However,
the two desks,
boats had a falling out in 1981 and I'm in left Libya for Saudi Arabia.
Life with the Saudis was a big come down for I'm in and his family they,
they now existed on handouts provided by the Saudi government.
He attempted to come back to Uganda in 1988 with a smaller group of armed
followers,
but nothing came of it.
The ends for the Mat.
Dictator came on August the 16th 2003 he had fallen into a coma at the month
before with his kidneys failing and no signs of recovery.
His family decided to turn off his life support.
He died with a quiet dignity.
The,
he denied so many of his victims on hearing about the death of his former army
chief mills and the Bowtie called,
I'm in the greatest brute than African mother has brought to life.
So sure.
Have you found that video?
Interesting?
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe brand new
videos just like this every day of the week.
Also,
thanks to dash lane,
please do check them out below and as always,
thank you for [inaudible]
watching.